-Today is Friday.
Today is Friday.
-Friday.
-I said Friday.
-Friday!
-Fried egg.
-Friday.
-Friday, Friday. Friday, Friday.
No, [stammers] I don't know.
I'm sorry.
I can't stop rapping.
-Yeah.
-It is Friday.
I'm feeling the weekend vibes,
right?
I need the weekend.
-Oh, my God.
-Come on.
I'm working for the weekend.
Usually, this is when I catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox
and I return some e-mails.
Of course, I send out
thank you notes,
and I was just running a bit --
Do you guys mind if I --
James, can I get some thank you
note writing music, please?
♪♪
Wow.
Thank you. Miami Heat
and Phoenix Suns logos,
for showing us that even
basketballs come in Flamin' Hot.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Flamin' hot.
Thank you original Flounder and
new Flounder for looking like
how someone
looks on Tinder versus
who actually shows up
for the date.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're Flounder?
-Wow.
-I guess I see it in the eyes.
-I guess so. Yeah.
-I'll take your word for it.
-It says here
Flounder is six-foot-two,
apparently.
-Do you have any ID?
[ Light laughter ]
-Thank you, James Corden,
for being the only TV host
who left their job
this week by choice.
[ Laughter ]
Love you, bud.
-Hey!
-Good job, buddy.
Gonna miss you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughter ]
He's a good dude.
Thank you, Roman soldiers,
for being the toughest people
in history to wear a broom.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, English Bulldogs,
for being jacked Beagles.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yoked!
-Slobbering!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, the White House
Correspondents Dinner,
for being nicknamed Nerd Prom,
or as -- or as I called that
in high school,
prom.
Love you, Ladee. Hi, Ladee.
I love you.
There you have it.
Those are my thank you notes.